- Is it true that it's
your first talk show?
- Yes, it is my first talk show.
- First talk show!
(audience applause)
Yes!
Okay, I might have made something for you.
I mean, whatever, Alison
made the really good one.
But like, which one would you like?
Which one would you like?
(laughter)
I'm just kidding.
- I mean.
- Which one?
- I love pink.
- Okay.
- It's a good color.
- You know what,
this is a special...
- This one's cute.
- That's the one.
- Something.
- [Alison] That's the one that you chose.
- This will go in my bedroom.
- Its a really messed up giraffe.
I just started.
- Great room decor.
- [Kelly] Don't judge me Ella.
- Okay (laughs).
(laughter)
- I just started.
I thought you were totally gonna
pick Alison's cause it's legit.
(laughter)
- I'm good with this one.
- I like you more for that.
So what was your first talk show Alison?
- I think it was Craig Ferguson.
- [Kelly] (gasp) Love Craig Ferguson.
- Yeah it was really fun.
- He's funny.
- He was so funny.
It was a really great time,
but I do remember getting...
I was very nervous.
- I'm nervous
- Yes and there's a lot
of people around you.
- Oh, this is so chill.
- This is very chill,
but there sometimes can be
people that stress you out.
(laughter)
Like, don't you get so stressed
and people stress you out?
- Oh my God.
- Like you should
be super stressed.
(laughter)
I think the best thing
is just to be yourself,
'cause everyone's trying to remind you
what to say and what to do and like--
- [Kelly] Just be you.
- You gotta just go with the flow.
- Yeah, and you're cool.
Great acting.
- (laughs) Thank you.
- You're so young.
Like to be doing that's crazy.
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
- What is the coolest thing,
about being a part of this movie?
- I think the coolest thing about
being part of this movie in particular,
is that Harley Quinn
doesn't care about anything,
she's just so crazy and it was so fun
to be with her and to just mess
around and be a kid on set.
- Yes, that's so fun.
Well it's good when you...
You'll learn that too, just
working on different sets
with different actors and
different people like,
especially if you start out so nice
with somebody that's really cool
and let's you just be you and
isn't giving added pressure.
Those are the jobs you want.
So your character Birds
of Prey is a pickpocket.
So did you study hard for that one?
(laughter)
Where's my wallet, is what I'm saying.
- I would be careful with that one.
(laughter)
But, a magician from the Magic Castle,
he came and taught me how to pickpocket
and how to work with a little
bit of magic and cards and--
- I've always wanted to
go to the Magic Castle,
like what did the do there?
It just seems like they pickpocket,
that's what they do.
- Pickpocket.
- Maybe I don't wanna go
there, I like my money.
So what is the key to stealing a wallet?
Just asking for a friend.
(laughter)
- Well a magician never
gives away their secrets.
- Oh, I like you, I like you.
(laughter)
Well we have a magician next,
so if you, if the both of you,
I always love asking people this,
usually it's after several
drinks, but don't drink.
- Okay (laughs).
- So what super power would you want,
if you could pick any super power?
- I think I'd want to be able to fly.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Because I,
- Yes!
- I mean,
(audience applause)
saving the world is great,
but just to be able to look at everything
and just like transportation.
- Yes!
You're like, "I'll be there in a second."
(whooshing sound)
No traffic.
- And you can flex
on all your friends, like, "I can fly,
"I'm taller than you."
(laughter)